ROCK, STUFF LIKE THAT.
AS THIS TURNS OUT THIS ALL MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE YESTERDAY, 3:00 IN
THE AFTERNOON, MORE PEOPLE FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES WOUND UP GOING
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
IT WAS AT 3:00 YESTERDAY
AFTERNOON THAT A COUPLE OF
PLANES WITH 50 VENEZUELAN
MIGRANTS ARRIVED.
>> Steve: IF YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOU ARE YOU ARE IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD ONE OF THE
MOST SPECTACULAR DESTINATIONS IN
THE WORLD.
>> Brian: NOT A GREAT TIME TO
BUY.
>> Steve: I DON'T THINK THEY ARE
IN THE MARKETED.
>> Brian: THEY ARE NOT?
IF YOU ARE APPEAR AGENT, AND YOU
HAVE ONE OF THOSE GOLD JACKETS.
>> Ainsley: FIND WORK THERE IN
NANTUCKET AND MARTHA'S VINEYARD
THEY HAVE ALL THESE CHRISTMAS
FESTIVAL THE CRANBERRY FESTIVAL.
THEY WILL NEED WORKERS.
>> Brian: THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
THERE FOR.
IT'S A MESSAGE.
WE HAVE A BORDER PROBLEM.
YOU ARE IGNORING THE BORDER
PROBLEM.
WE EVER BRINGING IT TO YOU.
RON DESANTIS SAID SIX OR EIGHT
MONTHS AGO.
YOU ARE LANDING PLANES IN
JACKSONVILLE THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT.
JENNINGS THING DEALING WITH
SCHOOL SYSTEMS OVERRUN WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
WE WEREN'T EVEN ALERTED ABOUT
THIS.
IF YOU ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT RON
DESANTIS FLYING PEOPLE IN AND
NOT GIVING YOU A HEADS UP.
JOIN THE CLUB.
THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T GIVE
ANYBODY A HEAD'S UP INCLUDING
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS.
>> Ainsley: WE ARE SANCTUARIES
STATES UP HERE BUT WE KNOW THE
REPUBLICANS STATE OF BEING
TEXAS, THE REPUBLICAN STATE OF
FLORIDA, YOU ARE FEELING, THIS
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
WE ARE THOUSANDS OF MILES AWAY.
AND THESE GOVERNORS ARE SAYING
IT'S NOT FAIR THAT WE TAKE ON
THIS BURDEN.
WE ARE ALSO GOING TO LET YOU
TAKE ON THIS BURDEN.
YOU ARE A SANCTUARY STATE.
SO YOU SAID YOU ARE GOING TO
WELCOME THEM.
SO WE WILL SEND THEM TO YOU.
>> Steve: DO YOU KNOW WHAT,
AINSLEY, TO YOUR POINT, RON
DESANTIS HIMSELF HAD MENTIONED
BEFORE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
ALL THESE MIGRANTS COMING TO
FLORIDA.
I'M GOING TO SEND THEM, HE SAID
A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO, TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD OR DELAWARE
WHICH IS JOE BIDEN'S HOME STATE
THAT WOULD GET EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION.
>> DESANTIS CONFIRMING YES WE
DID IN.
>> Steve: COMMUNICATIONS PERSON
PUT OUT THIS STATEMENT AND
STARTS LIKE THIS.
STATES LIKE MASSACHUSETTS, NEW
YORK AND CALIFORNIA WILL BETTER
FACILITATE THE CARE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WHO THEY HAVE
INVITED INTO OUR COUNTRY BY
INCENTIVIZING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION THROUGH THEIR
DESIGNATION AS SANCTUARY STATE
AND SUPPORT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S OPEN BORDER
POLICY.
>> Ainsley: WHAT THEY DID DOWN
IN FLORIDA THE LEGISLATURE.
THEY APPROPRIATED $12 MILLION TO
FACILITATE ALL OF THESE
TRANSPORTS.
THEY VOTED FOR, THIS AND NOW
THEY ARE SENDING THEM ELSEWHERE.
THEY SAY WE CAN'T HANDLE AS MANY
AS ARE COMING THROUGH OUR
BORDER.
>> Steve: IF YOU REMEMBER THOSE
STATISTICS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT
YESTERDAY.
EVERY ILLEGAL MIGRANT IN THIS
COUNTRY COST U.S. TAXPAYERS AT
LEAST $10,000 PER PERSON.
SO, YOU KNOW, THEY WENT INTO 50
VENEZUELANS IN THE COMMONWEALTH.
>> Ainsley: ONLY 50.
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY ARE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER IN TEXAS
DAILY.
>> Steve: 100 TIMES THAT NUMBER.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Brian: GET YOUR PHONE, GET
YOUR NEW OUTFIT.
GET YOUR PLACE TO LIVE.
ALL FOR FREE.
KNOW WHAT THIS MEANS?
I GOT TO WORRY ABOUT THIS.
WE SEND THIS VIDEO OUT AND SEEN
IN GUATEMALA, HONDURAS,
VENEZUELA, CUBA.
ALL AROUND THE SURROUNDING AREAS
AND SAY WE HAVE TO GO.
THIS IS THE ONE TIME IN WHICH
AMERICA HAS TOTALLY DROPPED ITS
GUARD.
AT TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
GO INTO OUR POCKET.
WE CAN LEAVE OUR LIFE; HOWEVER,
IT IS.
AND I GUARANTEE YOU IT WILL-EYE
WE WILL HAVE A BETTER LIFE IN
AMERICA.
NOW IS THE TIME.
REMEMBER THAT MEAN GUY THAT HAD
THE JOB LAST TIME.
HE DIDN'T WANT ANYBODY TO COME.
HE WANTED TO BUILD A WALL.
HE WANTED TO SET UP A SYSTEM
WHERE PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAD TO
SIGN IN AND IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE A
GOOD REASON FOR ASYLUM WHEN YOU
APPLIED IN MEXICO, YOU STAYED IN
MEXICO OR YOU WENT HOME AGAIN.
SO I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE COME
ONE, COME ALL.
GOVERNOR PRITZKER IS.
>> Ainsley: ILLINOIS.
>> Brian: OF ILLINOIS.
OBSTINATE MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
VERY CRUEL ABOUT HOW 300
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN BUSED OVER
TO CHICAGO.
HE CLEARLY WANTS TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AND BE ABOVE IT ALL.
>> Ainsley: THEY HAD A PRESS
CONFERENCE TOGETHER YESTERDAY
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT 500 ILLEGALS
HAVE BEEN SENT TO CHICAGO FROM
TEXAS IN THE PAST TWO WEEKS.
AND THEN WE HAVE INTERVIEWED
SOME OF THESE LOCAL MAYORS IN
THE SUBURBS OF CHICAGO BECAUSE
THEY ARE SAYING LORI LIGHTFOOT
IS SENDING THEM NOT SUBURBS TO
THE REPUBLICAN AREA TO BURR
RIDGE AND ELK RIDGE.
>> Steve: WITH NO NOTICE.
>> Ainsley: WHAT SHE COMPLAINED
ABOUT FROM THE STATE OF TEXAS.
>> Steve: IRONIC.
>> Ainsley: HERE IS THE GOVERNOR
AND LORI LIGHTFOOT.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO MINCE WORDS
HERE.
THE GOVERNOR OF TEXAS IS FORCING
ON NEW YORK AND D.C. AND CHICAGO
AND POTENTIALLY OTHER PLACES A
NEEDLESSLY LAST-MINUTE AND
COMPLEX PROCESS THAT IS A
HEARTLESS DISPLAY OF POLITICS
OVER PEOPLE WHY NOT GIVE
REASONABLE NOTICE?
WHY SEND THESE FOLKS ONLY TO
BLUE CITIES OR BLUE STATES?
THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS FOR HIM.
>> IT IS A MANUFACTURED CRISIS
BY AMBUSH.
ANY DOLLAR THAT GOES TO THE
STATE OF TEXAS.
>> EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
DOLLARS NEEDS TO BE RECOMMITTED
TO CITIES LIKE CHICAGO, NEW
YORK, AND WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Brian: I DON'T THINK IT'S
PLAYING POLITICS BECAUSE ALMOST
EVERY RED STATE SEES THIS AS A
PROBLEM.
ALMOST EVERY BLUE STATES IGNORES
OR SAYS IT IS A PROBLEM.
YOU DEAL WITH IT AND TELL US HOW
YOU ARE DOING.
EVEN IF YOU HAVE A HEADS UP.
GOVERNOR PRITZKER HAD TWO DAYS
TO PREPARE.
DO YOU WANT TO CHANGE OUTFITS,
CHANGE YOUR TIE?
THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE WHEN YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
TWO FLOORS INSTEAD OF ONE FLOOR
OF YOUR HOTEL.
THIS IS WHAT IS HAPPENING EVERY
DAY DESTROYING LIVES IN TEXAS.
-- EXCUSE ME, MAYOR ABBOTT.
YOU NOTICE, BEEN KIND OF QUIET.
HE HASN'T BEEN AS LOCAL.
HE IS LETTING ILLINOIS AND
CHICAGO SPECIFICALLY FIGHT IT
OUT AND WHAT HE SAYS IS
INTERESTING BECAUSE THERE IS
ONLY -- THERE IS A COUPLE OF
THOUSAND FROM COME FROM TEXAS.
>> Ainsley: 2200.
>> Brian: COUPLE THOUSAND,
RIGHT?
7,000 COME THROUGH THE SUMMER
JUST PEOPLE MAKING THEIR WAY
HERE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
IN THIS NEW AND UNFORESEEN
RELATES WHERE WE ARE EXPECTED --
WHERE WE EXPECTED THOUSANDS TO
ARRIVE EVERY WEEK GOING FORWARD.
THE CITY SYSTEM IS NEARING ITS
BREAK POINT.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY ASYLUM
SYSTEM IS SNAPPED OVER ON
MONDAY, THEY TURNED AWAY ABOUT
60 -- AT LEAST 60 PEOPLE FROM
HOMELESS SHELTERS.
I IMAGINE IT'S MORE.
AND THEY HAVE A SYSTEM AND
ADVOCATE IS GOING TO SUE THE
CITY BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE,
ILLEGALS AND NON-ILLEGAL
HOMELESS WENT FOR SHELTERS AND
WERE ALREADY PACKED.
>> Ainsley: THINK ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU SAY 7,000 ARE GOING TO
COME TO NEW YORK OR HAVE COME TO
NEW YORK AND ABBOTT HAS BUSED
2200, THAT IS LESS THAN 10,000,
RIGHT?
ARE HE SAYS THAT'S HIS BREAKING
POINT?
YET, LOOK AT EL PASO, LOOK AT
THESE CITIES DOWN IN TEXAS WHEN
THEY ARE GETTING 5,000 A DAY.
>> Steve: RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, THE GOVERNOR OF THE
GREAT STATE OF TEXAS TWEETED
THIS OUT.
SANCTUARY CITY MAYORS COMPLAIN
THEY ARE OVERWHELMED BY A FEW
DOZEN MIGRANTS ARRIVING ON BUSES
FROM TEXAS.
IT IS A FRACTION OF WHAT TEXAS
FACES ON A DAILY BASIS.
WE WILL CONTINUE BUSING MIGRANTS
UNTIL JOE BIDEN SECURES THE
BORDER.
AND WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT?
HE IS TALKING ABOUT ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ESSENTIALLY BEING
ALLOW IN THE COUNTRY BY THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
WHERE DO THEY GO?
A THOUSAND MIGRANTS HAVE SHOWN
UP IN EL PASO THIS WEEK.
WHAT IS THAT YOU SEE ON THE
STREET?
THOSE ARE PEOPLE SLEEPING ON THE
STREET BECAUSE EL PASO CAN'T
HANDLE THEM.
THEY THERE ARE NO TOILETS, NO
SHOWERS.
IT'S VERY UNSANITARY.
MANY ARE BEING DROPPED OFF NEAR
THE BUS STATION AND LEFT TO FEND
FOR THEMSELVES.
THE U.S. CONGRESSMAN FROM THAT
REGION TONY GONZALES LIKENED EL
PASO TO A THIRD WORD COUNTRY.
HE SAID IT'S ALMOST APOCALYPTIC.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING.
THIS LOOK AT THOSE PUP TENTS.
>> Brian: WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO
COMMENT?
WHEN ARE THEY GOING TO ASK ABOUT
THIS.
SOMEONE PUT UP THEIR iPHONE IS
THIS OKAY WITH YOU KARINE
JEAN-PIERRE.
>> Steve: THAT'S WHY WE ARE
RUNNING IT BECAUSE NO OTHER
CHANNEL ASKS ABOUT IT.
WHEN IT WE ASK SHE SAID THERE IS
SECURE BORDER.
WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT TEXAS I DON'T
WANT MY TOWN TO LOOK LIKE
PORTLAND.
PEOPLE IN PORTLAND PROBABLY IN
THE COUNTRY LEGALLY.
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEING ALLOWED
INTO THE COUNTRY DURING THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND NOW THEY ARE
DEPENDING FOR THEMSELVES.
YOU HAVE GOT TO FEEL SORRY FOR
THOSE PEOPLE; HOWEVER, THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE LIKE ABBOTT AND RON
DESANTIS WHO ARE SAYING, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
TERRIBLE CONDITIONS HERE.
LET'S SEND THEM TO SOME PLACE
WHERE THEY HANDLE THEM.
SO THEY SENT 50 VENEZUELANS
YESTERDAY TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THEY WERE TAKEN TO THE
ST. ANDREW'S EPISCOPAL CHURCH IN
EDGAR TOWN WHICH HAS BEEN USED
AS A HOMELESS SHELTER IN THE
PAST.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE BEING TAKEN
CARE OF NOW BY THE COMMONWEALTH
OF MASSACHUSETTS.
AS THESE RED STATE GOVERNORS TRY
TO EQUAL THINGS OUT.
>> Brian: MAYBE BARACK OBAMA
WILL GET TO KNOW HIM AND THEY
WILL BE INVITED TO HIS NEXT
SHINDIG.
I MISSPOKE.
ACCORDING TO MAYOR AADAMS, HE
SAYS NEARLY 11 THOWMS PEOPLE
HAVE STREAMED INTO NEW YORK CITY
SINCE THE SUMMER.
AND HE SAYS WE HAVE TO REASSESS
OUR SHELTER POLICY.
NO KIDDING.
>> Steve: BRIAN A LOT OF THOSE
PEOPLE COME TO NEW YORK BECAUSE
WHEN THEY'RE DOWN ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER BEING PROCESSED
THEY WILL SAY ICE AUTHORITIES
DEPARTMENT HOMELAND SECURITY
SAYS GO SEE THIS GUY, THIS ICE
AGENT IN NEW YORK.
AND THEY WILL GO I DON'T KNOW
ANYBODY IN NEW YORK.
AND IT'S LIKE WELL, THAT'S GOING
TO